- All hour, we celebrated
Hip Hop's 50th anniversary.
And now I have one more story to share.
This is What I'm Liking.
At the top of the show I said Hip hop
has touched every part of our culture.
Even the culinary arts.
Everybody, Louisville, Kentucky is home
to a hip hop theme bakery known
as the Hip Hop Sweet Shop.
They're famous for their
milkshakes, which are awesome.
There's the K R S One A K
A, the Caramel Apple Pie.
There's Diddy's,
I need a girl Strawberry
Cheesecake Milkshake.
And there's the Eight
Mile Cookies and Cream,
which looks incredible.
Let's get the owner in here right now.
Everybody say hello to Lafesa
watching on W D R B T tv.
What's up Lafesa?
- Hey guys.
- I love your shirt.
I love some Tupac.
So tell us how you came up with
the idea in the first place.
- Well, I've been baking for 16 years
and I decided to combine my love
for hip hop and baking
and open a mobile bakery
in the urban community that I lived in.
Everything that we make is named
after hip hop artists, hip hop
songs, lingo, record labels.
Um, We actually suffered
a devastating fire
on December the 21st.
We've started a GoFundMe
and the community is
really rallying together
to help us raise funds to
come back bigger and better.
- I'm so sorry.
And right before Christmas.
That sucks.
That had to be,
- Yeah.
- It's already devastating enough.
But especially on the holidays,
that's a, that's a hard hit.
So how is the rebuilding coming along?
- It is coming along.
Uh, the community is really supporting our
GoFundMe to help raise funds to rebuild.
I tell them that,
if we can survive Covid,
we will definitely,
definitely survive this and
come back bigger and stronger.
- Absolutely. Thank you so much, Lafesa.
I'm liking your post right now
and I wish I had one of
your milkshakes right now.
Especially that Eight Mile, girl.
Uh, That's not all though.
Our season long partner
Pilot pen makers of G2
the go-to pen of the Kelly Clarkson Show,
want to help the Hip
Hop Sweet Shop reopen.
So they're gonna be writing you a check
for a thousand dollars.
How's that sound?
(applause)
- Oh my God.
Thank you so much.
- Absolutely.
- Wasn't expecting that at all.
- Oh my goodness. Thank you.
- Aw, you have a beautiful
smile, by the way.
Alright, well thank you and
thank you so much everybody
for celebrating 50 years
of Hip Hop with us today.
And a big thank you to all of our guests.
Chance the Rapper, Angie Martinez,
Marquan Shumpert, Ziggy and DJ Cassidy.
Y'all have a great day and if it's not,
try and change it.